MIKKO KOSKINEN FOR LATE MARCH I.
BEHIND THE NET, DRAISAITLVE ON .
IS TRYING TO GENERATE SOME
OFFENSE.
'S.A Matt: HAYTON OFF THE FACE
>> Matt: FAGO FOUR-ON-FOUR.
Mc
FORCES IT BACK TO THE COYOTES
AND.
MCDAVID TO DRAISAITL
I CANNOT REMEMBER THE LAST TIME
I'VE SEEN A POWER PLAY
>> TysonHAS GOT IT.
TRYING TO GET AROUND MONSTER OF.
THE PUCK JUST FOLLOWS MCDAVID W.
>> Tyson: CONNOR MCDAVID
HERE'S A LOOK AT IN
FRONT AND CODY TO THE OUTSIDE AL
.
>> Matt: MCDAVID IN FRONT UP NOW
MCDAVID TO THE FRONT NET.
DRAISAITL SETS HANDLE IN THE PY
SEASON. OF THE
GAME.
THE FIRST POWER PLAY BY MCDAVID
IN THE FIRST.
FINALLY THE COYOTES GET A HOLD
OF THIS ONE.
GOSTISBEHERE WILL GETTL.
KEPT BY KELLER.
MCDAVID WILL TURN THE OTHER WAS
TO STAY ON-SIDE FOR THIS PLAY O
NOT..